there is a new poll out from Washington
Post ABC News take it with whatever
grain of salt you want that Donald Trump
is up seven points not up seven points
over DeSantis up seven points over Joe
Biden you're hard trouble reading this
has 49 of respondents said they
would definitely or probably vote for
Trump against Biden or that they lean
toward voting for Trump or is Biden in
such a scenario only gets 42 percent now
they pulled the same question with
DeSantis curiously DeSantis doesn't do
as well as Trump pretty close and he's
up over Biden by the same amount seven
points but only 48 percent of people say
that they would definitely or probably
vote for DeSantis over Biden and 41
percent of people say they would vote
for Biden over DeSantis these are still
good numbers for DeSantis the DeSantis
campaign is far from over though they do
have an uphill battle but this this is
bad news for them because if this keeps
up then DeSantis loses the best argument
he has for his candidacy which is I'm
Trump without the downsides I'm Trump
who can win